[Música]
y nuestra segunda invitada del día está
en Colombia país donde hoy el movimiento
causa justa celebra el primer
aniversario del fallo histórico que
despenalizó el aborto hasta la semana 24
una medida progresista que dejó este
país con uno de los Marcos legales más
garantistas del mundo en relación a los
derechos reproductivos de las personas
con capacidad de gestar se trata de un
acceso Digno y sin discriminación O al
menos ese es el objetivo para conversar
sobre este tema está en France 24
Juliana Martínez ella es politóloga
magister en género y diversidad doctor
en ciencias humanas y sociales y también
secretaria técnica del movimiento causa
justa por la eliminación del delito del
aborto Juliana gracias a usted por estar
con nosotros muchas gracias a ustedes
por la invitación y la posibilidad de
explicar que ha pasado en este primer
año de la sentencia causa justa Bueno
nos compete entonces hacer el primer
balance después de un año de que se haya
dado esta sentencia histórica Cómo ha
sido la implementación de la medida
Julia y que tanta resistencia han
evidenciado ustedes yo creo que podemos
organizar el balance del primer año de
esta sentencia entre ese aspectos uno
inmediato que está relacionado con el
poder simbólico pero también lo que
significa en términos legales que en
Colombia hoy una mujer un hombre trans o
una persona no binaria pueda acercarse
al sistema de salud con confianza sin
saber sabiendo que no va a ser
criminalizada por solicitar un servicio
de salud entonces ahí tenemos una
ganancia inmediata que además como tú
mencionas es un referente para otros
países no solo en América Latina sino
también en el mundo por otro lado
tendríamos que hablar de la
implementación Y aquí los datos
preliminares que tenemos de la fundación
orientame nos muestran que en este
primer año se atendieron alrededor de
11.600 mujeres y este dato tiene dos
lecturas por un lado no hay un aumento
Respecto a los mismos datos del periodo
anterior en esta fundación que se
especializa en servicios de salud sexual
y reproductiva y por otro lado las
atenciones siguen concentradas el 93% en
menos de 12 semanas de adje gestacional
hay que tener aquí en cuenta que no hay
datos oficiales el país tiene un rezago
en las cifras sobre aborto y este es un
llamado de atención sobre alguna de las
cosas que se requiere para poder hacer
una mejor lectura de la implementación
Pero además Hay que decir que en marzo
la mesa por la vida y la salud de las
mujeres que es una organización la
pionera de causa justa presentará un
informe y el tercer aspecto en el que
podríamos entrar Este primer año de
implementación es precisamente la
despenalización social y es poder tener
unas conversaciones transparentes
tranquilas basadas en argumentos sobre
lo que significa que las mujeres puedan
decidir en libertad sobre su vida Ahí
seguimos teniendo un enorme reto porque
sigue habiendo desinformación al
respecto bueno y Porque además estas son
medidas que No necesariamente vulneran a
las mujeres o las personas más
privilegiadas sino precisamente a las
más vulnerables le pido que hablemos de
cifras pensando en compasión pensando en
la diversidad de opiniones alrededor de
este tema del aborto que no es solo en
Colombia sino a nivel mundial hay que
aclarar que la mayoría de abortos como
algunas cifras no muestran se producen
en etapas tempranas y cuando esto no
sucede tiene mucho más que ver con la
falta de acceso a los sistemas de salud
con casos en los que hablamos de las
supuestas niñas madres Víctimas de
violencia sexual y especialmente toca a
las que están en zonas Rurales en los
lugares más vulnerables del país esa es
un aspecto muy importante para entender
qué ha pasado este año y que tiene que
ver con las barreras de acceso Las
barreras de acceso hacen son una
constante en la forma como las mujeres
lo que viven las mujeres cuando
solicitan el servicio de interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo Pero además
afecta de manera más severa a las
mujeres con mayores vulnerabilidades de
hecho este es uno de los aspectos en los
que se centra el análisis de la corte
que conduce a la decisión de tener
aborto Libre hasta la semana 24 porque
plantea precisamente ese plazo en
función de las barreras dificultades que
pueden vivir mujeres que están en
lugares apartados que han sido Víctimas
de violencia sexual y que no es fácil
tomar la decisión mujeres Rurales y por
ejemplo mujeres migrantes en situación
irregular que no tienen Claro que en el
país Es legal para todas las mujeres y
es uno de los servicios incluidos en el
plan de beneficios en salud este
servicio y que además si no están
afiliadas al sistema de salud aplica el
exceso a través de las urgencias
entonces lo que hemos evidenciado es que
Precisamente en zonas periféricas del
país donde hay desinformación donde no
están disponibles los servicios las
mujeres viven más Barreras y en algunos
casos tienen que desplazarse a ciudades
capitales cercanas como Bogotá Medellín
Cali Barranquilla para poder acceder a
un servicio sin hablar que unos momentos
el sistema de salud No beneficia y
aplaza los procedimientos de manera que
se salen del marco legal ahora otro tema
que se discute mucho es la condena
social no y en eso trabaja muchísimo el
movimiento de causa justa la decisión de
una mujer de interrumpir un embarazo no
cambia lo que sí cambia es si es un
procedimiento legal o clandestino y aquí
Lo importante es cuando se salvan vidas
Cuáles son las particularidades del
aborto en Colombia en Colombia y para
que todas las personas que nos están
viendo lo tengan claro el aborto es
libre por decisión de la mujer hasta la
semana 24 en ese caso no se requiere
ningún requisito posterior a eso aplican
las causales que fueron despenalizadas
desde el 2006 y hay que precisar que a
partir de la resolución 051 del 2023
expedida por el Ministerio de salud
existen cada vez menos excusas por
supuesto la jurisprudencia de la corte
ha sido Clara sobre esto pero entendemos
que para del sector salud es importante
tener
reunidas en un único instrumento
normativo las reglas de funcionamiento Y
eso es lo que hace la resolución de mi
salud en la que además hay que destacar
la voluntad del gobierno nacional para
cumplir una orden expresa de la corte
ahí están contenidas las características
del servicio en el país por ejemplo que
debe estar disponible en todo el
territorio de nacional en todos los
niveles de atención y el esfuerzo que
está haciendo ahí el Ministerio es por
concentrar la prestación del servicio en
el nivel primario que es precisamente
para edades gestacionales tempranas
menos de la 12 lo que permitiría además
ahorrar costos al sistema pues Juliana
lo que quería lo que quisiera yo ver es
en el informe los datos sobre cómo se
están llevando a cabo estas aplicaciones
y cómo se están viendo reflejados estos
esfuerzos en el sistema de salud a
partir de la sentencia de la corte pero
también hay que hablar inevitablemente
de política pública el aborto al final
cree usted podría en muchos casos una
consecuencia de falta de ella de falta
de derechos reproductivos al final si lo
que se quiere como pregonan los
movimientos provida es evitar más
abortos más que una legislación que los
prohíba no cree usted que nos
beneficiaríamos por ejemplo de un pleno
derecho a decidir de Educación para
planear las maternidades o para planear
no tenerlas ese es un punto muy
interesante porque este cambio de
paradigma Precisamente lo que muestra es
que el uso del derecho penal no puede
ser la única política pública que
implementa el estado con relación a un
asunto de salud como el aborto en su
lugar lo que propone la corte y la que
también ha sido una apuesta del
movimiento causa justa es desarrollar
una política pública integral en materia
de salud sexual y salud reproductiva que
aborde distintos aspectos Como por
ejemplo la educación sexual integral que
las personas tengan conocimiento de
acuerdo con su edad sobre lo que pueden
hacer con su reproducción que accedan a
métodos anticonceptivos modernos que
tengan información veraz oportuna y
Clara y además por supuesto la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
entonces lo que sigue para el país es
precisamente eso y vuelvo a los datos
preliminares de la fundación oriéntame
porque uno de los aspectos que muestran
que van mostrando es que en efecto está
aumentando el acceso a través de la cps
mire nos quedan poquísimos segundos
porque las maternidades deben ser
deseadas porque es un derecho de las
mujeres Porque además la reproducción ha
sido un aspecto definitorio de la
identidad de las mujeres y en esa medida
las mujeres debemos tomarlas por nuestra
cuenta poder decidir y que se reconozca
la capacidad que tenemos de hacerlo no
somos meros receptáculos para dar la
vida sino que esa debe ser una decisión
consciente y acorde al proyecto de vida
Juliana Martínez secretaria técnica del
movimiento causa justa por la
eliminación del delito del aborto
gracias a usted a ustedes Muchas gracias
y la maternidad
deseada gracias a ustedes sigan con
nosotros y ya volvemos con más de
directo a América
[Música]